DON DODGE: Hi, I'm Don Dodge.
And this is "Google Root
Access," the show for startups
about issues that every
startup has.
Today, we're going to
talk about user
experience and user design.
I have a special guest, Nazmul
Idris, who works on the
Android team and focuses
on user design.
Thanks for joining us.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Thank you.
I'm glad to be here.
DON DODGE: So, you talked about
reducing friction and
creating a great first
minute experience.
So what do you mean
by friction?
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's a
very good question.
If you were to measure the
emotional response a user has
when they're interacting with
your application, and let's
say those responses were
negative, if they were angry
or frustrated, anything that
causes a negative reaction or
negative emotional reaction
is considered friction.
So it's not just that it's
good practice not to have
friction in your applications.
If you consider prospect
theory, which is a
psychological thing, it tells
us that for every negative
interaction you have with
something, you need three
positive interactions.
So for a startup with limited
funding, limited everything,
it's much easier to remove
friction than to come up with
really amazing experiences
to delight someone.
So it's good for startups to
get into the mindset of
removing friction and delighting
rather than just
delighting but then also leaving
friction in, which now
you have to work three times
as hard, essentially.
DON DODGE: So by friction do you
mean preventing the user
from getting at the meat of
what they want to do, like
putting steps that they have
to take or sign up or that
kind of thing?
Is that what you mean
by friction?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
So it's important for your
application to understand that
the user has a limited amount
of bandwidth, limited amount
of focus or cognitive load.
Like you can't just ask people
to do complex things without
actually first letting them
know what the value
proposition is for them to
actually take those actions.
Additionally, you want to
simplify those complex actions
as much as possible.
So it's very deep in
how you have to
consider removing friction.
DON DODGE: So most applications
have an account
creation process, sign-in
process, maybe they have a
walk-through or demo or
something that they make you
go through.
What's your advice on
that kind of thing?
How do you handle account
creation or demos or
walk-throughs?
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's a
very good question.
The most important thing right
away when you actually first
experience an application is
for the application to give
you an idea of what
it's going to do.
And if it needs you do
something like sign
in to tell you why.
Then you'll be more eager
to actually, for
example, sign in.
Now, once you've understood why
you need to sign in and
then you go to sign in, the
application developer should
take a lot of effort to remove
any friction from
that step as well.
So that involves using something
like sign in with
Google, or log in with
Facebook, or
something like that.
Does that make sense?
DON DODGE: Yeah.
So my son has an app that he
built, and he required
Facebook sign in to create an
account before you got going.
And he called it the
Facebook wall.
Because a big percentage of
the users wouldn't do that
because they hadn't yet seen
the value of the app.
So he allowed them to get into
the app and start using it and
do a few things before
requesting that
they create an account.
So is that an example of
friction and how you might
handle making it work?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yes.
That's a great example.
So what your son did was instead
of putting the onus on
the user to do something that
they didn't know that they
wanted to do, they are
continuing to interact and
engage with the application,
which makes them want to
engage with it more.
And the more they want, the more
they'll interact with it.
And they're OK with spending
more time and energy with the
application once they have an
idea that there's going to be
a good reward.
DON DODGE: So that's sort of
like progressive disclosure or
progressive disclosure of
features, where you give them
more, don't overwhelm them
in the beginning.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
And not only that, but if you
consider things like sign in
or sharing, you don't need
permissions to do
everything up front.
So let the user kind of flow
through the application a
little bit.
And when they need to do
something, whether they need
to be signed in, or they need
to share, then kind of load
them with kind of overcoming
that step.
DON DODGE: So let's say I have
a rather complex application
that has lots of features and
lots of surface area.
How do I make that first
minute experience be
delightful?
NAZMUL IDRIS: So that's actually
not easy to do.
But if we use an example like
Google Now, that's actually a
fantastic, fantastic example
of how to do it right.
If you consider Google Now,
it's taking into account a
tremendous number of signals.
It's a very complicated thing.
But when you first launch Google
Now, it gives you like
a sample card.
And it kind of gets
you thinking.
It basically says, hey, if you
sign in, or if you opt in to
using Google Now, these are the
amazing things that you
might be able to do.
It doesn't really contextualize
them for you yet.
It just gives you samples.
So then you say,
OK, yes I'm in.
That's the message.
Then it starts showing
you sample cards.
And those sample cards aren't
yet tailored to your life.
Or it's just giving like, for
example, the weather.
The simple things.
The idea there is that as you
live in Google Now more and
more, Google Now unlocks
more and more and more
capabilities, and it asks you
to customize it more or
interact with it more.
And so it doesn't feel
like friction.
It feels like it's enticing you
to do something that you
wanted to do.
And it's delighting you with
unexpected things you didn't
even know you needed, but
when it showed you,
you were like, wow.
I didn't know you
could do that.
So that's the reaction that
we're trying to get.
It's that moment of delight.
And those can be engineered.
It's not random that those
things happen.
It takes a lot of work,
but it can be done.
DON DODGE: So making that first
minute experience to be
delightful is really,
really important.
Progressive disclosure of
features and letting them into
it, reducing friction, those
are the keys to making it
successful.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
DON DODGE: Great.
Well, thank you for
joining us.
That was a great show.
Join us again when we
cover other topics
of interest to startups.
I have a special offer
for you for "Google
Root Access" viewers.
We're offering a $2,000 credit
for the Google Cloud Platform.
So if you're a developer that's
developing an app that
uses a cloud backend, it's a
great opportunity for you to
get started and get
a $2,000 credit.
Thank you very much
for joining us.